welcome back to the stronger by science
fireside chat series i am your one and
only host greg knuckles joined today by
a special temporary
[ __ ] let's try that again i like it
i say we keep it special temporary guest
co-host eric trexler eric how are you
doing today
i'm doing great how are you uh just fine
that was that was an allergy cough uh
just making sure the listeners are aware
of that don't send cards don't send
flowers
i have so much more life to live um
so yeah and now that we've now that
we've definitely set a good vibes
environment
um how's it going man uh
things are good uh weather's nice we
could do an hour on weather today i
think i think people would like that
dude we really could it's been it's been
gray
and overcast and pretty cold and very
rainy in north carolina
and the last three days have been
beautiful
um and i'm here for it yeah 70
fahrenheit which converts to
some integer well probably not an
integer in celsius but a number i think
it's
like 20s yeah thereabouts it's just been
pleasant
but we are getting to that point of of
the year where you are
essentially dead yeah yeah i was gonna
say i get
about a week of being able to enjoy
spring
uh you know the sun gets warmer
everything's brighter
uh and then as soon as i start being
able to smell flowers
i know i am in danger um
but for the time being it is that that
blessed time of year where it's getting
warm but nothing is blooming yet
uh and i can really enjoy it all right
uh so yeah fireside chat we're talking
about off topic stuff these are
questions that we solicited
from the stronger by science subreddit
and the stronger by science community
facebook group
if you would like to get your questions
in either for just
normal podcast episodes uh for the
podcast
that eric does that i'm in no way
affiliated with or
for fireside chats uh you know join the
facebook group
join the reddit community and you will
have an opportunity to ask your
questions
um you know before we get into the
listener questions i
you know we're looking for questions
from all over the place right
yeah and my girlfriend sent me a link
that was like
icebreaker questions like almost kind of
first date type questions oh geez
and i don't know why she had it so quick
it seemed
it seemed bookmarked so i that's a
different conversation we'll have to
have off air
do you want to start with some of those
uh no i didn't read them
it just immediately became just so we
can get to know each other better
you know it was i it became a very
contentious argument i didn't even open
the link
as it should yeah uh all right so let's
get right into it
um patrick james barney asks a question
that would probably be
best for trex to lead with what are your
feelings on
ohio state shot at the title next year
you know i saw this question we're going
this is our first ever like
fully unprepared fireside chat where
we're not looking at the same outline so
i might get stumped but this one didn't
stump me um
i knew this one was coming and it made
me think about
previous ohio state playoff runs
and the only thing i know for certain is
that you cannot predict them
so like when you think back to 2014
ezekiel elliott
honestly had like a pretty slow year and
then
the playoffs came we put in our third
string quarterback and we put up like 70
points a game
you couldn't have guessed that personnel
who would be the key contributors there
same thing goes this year we didn't win
a title but we made it there
and uh yeah a running back who was
really a role player the whole season
all of a sudden i guess gets like 300
yards a game
that was just like a normal thing he did
at the end of the year so
i have no idea but i i do think the
program's in a healthy spot
and so i like our chances i'd say at the
very least we should still
be interested in the season at the end
yes so i would say that there is a 100
percent chance that ohio state wins the
title this year
uh if you haven't already uh taken out a
home equity loan
to put down a bigger bet uh you're a
fool
the the line is only going to get less
and less favorable for you as a better
over time
uh put put all your chips not on red
not on black but on the scarlet and grey
um
that's that's my take you know what that
reminds me of
is um one time game stock
no game stop two weeks ago no
one time a very reputable business coach
reached out to me on facebook
he saw that i was you know an aspiring
fitness coach he wanted to help me turn
that into a nine-figure business with
high ticket revenue
and he reached out and i kind of just
like wasn't picking up what he was
putting down
and he hit me with this question that i
think you basically hit the listeners
with
do you hate money if you do hate money
ignore greg's advice if you don't hate
money take his advice and also sign up
for that person's business coaching yeah
uh so on that topic this is something
that
uh like three or four people did ask
about but i didn't put on the outline uh
but but on the topic of
do you hate money type interactions uh
someone hit me up on instagram a couple
days ago
and uh i don't know exactly what kind of
scam he was trying to pull but he was a
big crypto guy
and he was basically just like look if
you give me money i'll cut you in on my
crypto mining operation
and that will make you you know untold
sums of wealth and uh
i was just like dude crypto mining has
an enormous carbon footprint
uh i do too by virtue of the fact that i
have like a fairly
typical american lifestyle uh
i don't really want to contribute to
that like like
crypto mining has a carbon footprint i
read
comparable to it was some small european
nation i think it was denmark
like i think the total energy cost of
crypto mining
is comparable to the total electricity
usage
on a yearly basis in denmark um so i was
like yeah man
hard pass uh like i don't know
i'm fine and he's like trying to guilt
me about it using every hard sell tactic
in the book
um you know like dude like this is
literally free money
if you put if you it felt like uh it
felt like pat robertson like on the 700
club
uh like you know if if you sow 100
you will reap much much much larger
uh as if it's like an immutable law of
the universe but
yeah i've been uh i've been chatting
with that guy for like two weeks at this
point and uh
eventually he's going to stop responding
because
i i keep feigning enough interest
that he keeps messaging me
uh but it's like you know okay i see
what you're saying and then like pull
back a little bit
uh hopefully that has a satisfying
conclusion
dude if you ever miss a deadline i'm
gonna say let me see your phone
how many scammers are you indulging
right now because
you this is your thing i mean you nearly
joined the illuminati the other day
oh my god yes and i know we have a lot
to do
so the next time you miss a deadline i'm
going to say all right
phone out what scams are you
entertaining
oh my god i forgot about that uh
yeah this guy who's um
like i don't even know if this was a
scam i think i think this guy
legitimately thinks he's part of the
illuminati
like his entire instagram was like
you know brother so and so elder cleric
of the illuminati
like everything he posted was about the
illuminati
and he reached out to me and he's like
do you want to join the ranks of the
illuminati elite and i said yes
absolutely i'm very interested in doing
so uh
and he said like okay so um first you
need to agree to our terms and
conditions
and he lays out a lot of terms and
conditions one of which is
and i i realize i'm shooting myself in
the foot here um
if you join the illuminati you cannot
let anyone else know that you are a
member of the illuminati
and like you go his [ __ ] instagram
display name was like
brother george chief elder of the
illuminati and it's like okay that's
that's not really adding up um but
anyway
like it was just like standard terms and
conditions like
you know be nice to people don't tell
anyone
like whatever and i was like okay cool i
i agree to all of this
um am i in now and he's like okay
now you need to download whatsapp to
join our to join the illuminati whatsapp
group
and i said look man i'm already too
spread across
the internet like there's way too many
things that i'm already like responding
to messages on
uh how did people join the illuminati
before whatsapp and
he's like this is the way it's always
been
so i guess i'm to believe that like i
don't know when whatsapp started but
like the the illuminati i guess
didn't exist until like 2012 which was
news to me
yeah but yeah i i love talking to people
like that on instagram it's uh
it's it's one of my passions
uh all right let's let's move on um
matt turner asks what pre-coveted
activity are you most looking forward to
when life returns to normal again um
so i gotta be honest um
i'm mostly looking forward to doing
stuff that other people like
um i i'm fully content living the way i
live currently
and i think you know that to be true oh
yes i haven't changed
much um but but i still
empathize with with the fact that people
around me
are living a very different life than
they used to and they want to go back to
things so like
for example i'm certain that many of my
friends want to go back to breweries and
have beers there
that would be terrific i i enjoy that uh
i know my girlfriend wants to go
have brunch somewhere which is
ridiculous because
i could easily make toast uh and beans
you know so like i could do brunch but
she doesn't appreciate my cooking
as much as our listeners do but just
little stuff like that going to the
brewery
uh you know going to brunch but that's
pretty much it for me what about you
yeah so uh as alluded to um
you know regarding joining the
illuminati i'm really big on joining
secret societies
um and one of one of the issues there is
a lot of them
uh you join like a blood pact you know
you
uh you cut your hand the other person
cuts their hand you shake your blood
intermingles
it's a blood bond like it's and that's a
safe thing well
it's not anymore and that's that's the
problem uh
i have not been able to join a single
new secret society since
since like january of last year um
and yeah i'm really getting the itch
again uh
i should download whatsapp anyway
no to to answer the question seriously
um
so the the only thing that i the only
thing that i typically do
on a weekly or did on a weekly basis
that i don't anymore
is uh play trivia at a bar and
we we could probably start doing that
again because like
they're still doing the trivia and like
it's outside the tables are separated
people wear masks uh instead of everyone
congregating around the scores table
when they're bringing their
their answer sheet up now you uh you
like
submitted via an app uh so like we could
probably do that again but
i mean part of the vibe was just being
able to to hang with friends you know
uh get nice and loose eat some garlic
knots drink some beer
uh and so i don't know like i'm i'm
looking forward to being able to go back
to trivia with like normal trivia vibes
i i think that's probably the biggest
thing for me
you know i think that is a good point
it's it's one of the reasons i haven't
explored certain things that would be
doable
it's just because i'm like well the
whole the whole reason i liked it was
the carefree vibe
and yeah it's very different to go in
and feel like everybody's
you know walking on eggshells and trying
to follow these various protocols and
stuff which are important but
for me i'm kind of like whatever i'll
just have a beer at home and
instead of here's my thing instead of
doing preset trivia questions i just
think about stuff
and it's just as fun
makes sense to me all right uh marcus
adan
asks zombie survival gear only what you
can carry on your person what is it
and why you know i've thought about that
before and uh
i think i'm good like i'm just
i if the zombie apocalypse kicked off is
that the the scenario here i i guess so
yeah
i would just go try to find a place uh
on a lake or a stream with fish
and and i would just kind of camp out
there and if the zombies come by and get
me like that's fine i don't think i'd
i don't think i'd be too troubled by it
yeah that's fair
like you know some people are like oh no
i really want to
survive the next 60 years of this barren
hellscape i'd be like ah it's probably
gonna get me at some point
yeah i mean so for me the the whole uh
zombie genre doesn't really do it for me
like
as we've as we've talked about on the
podcast before uh
i am a determinist i don't believe free
will exists
i don't think existence as a zombie
would really be that fundamentally
different
than normal existence you'd eat more
brains
yeah i mean i think yeah it's honestly
it seems like a simple life
you know um instead of being troubled
by all of your earthly desires there
would just be the one yeah you just want
more brains just brains that's all
uh yeah no worries just
just good vibes and brains um see i i
don't know
i uh i would probably
yeah do something similar just try to
get somewhere fairly rural
um yeah and just kind of like hang out
live a simple life uh you know really
only focus
on like have a life where i'm really
just focusing on basic tasks of survival
anyway
and honestly at that point if i did get
zombified i don't know that my
day-to-day would change that much
um instead of like you know
going and finding berries or you know
trying to get a fish out of the stream
you're just
getting brains right exactly uh
that really tempted me to make a joke
that probably wouldn't be great for a
christian family friendly podcast
yeah uh you can stay on brand yeah you
can fill in the blank studio i'm such a
pure
a pure heart i didn't even go there
mentally
uh okay um all right moving on
uh this this is a good one for eric
uh joseph smith asks i for one would
love to hear
eric expand on his experience with
online dating
that was responsible for the advice of
and i quote
if you can't go down to the courthouse
and get married today because you're
already married
then that is too married um
i think that i have given you all the
information that would possibly be
necessary to connect those dots but
if the listeners need an explicit
connection of those
dots uh i did indeed date someone
who purported to be fully
single uh which is mutually exclusive
with being married correct
what's that one would assume if
someone's saying they're single
that is mutually exclusive with being
married
yes yeah it wasn't like well i'm in this
marriage but it's an open marriage kind
of deal no it was just
a very simple straightforward single
uh not like um you know in the process
of a divorce but it's not done yet
just single that was just the whole
explanation
um and as you would probably imagine
from the contextual clues that
did not turn out to be the case uh there
was a lot more
marriage in that situation that i than i
had been led to believe
uh so that led to conflict within our
dynamic
um you know uh but that was i i think
that's pretty clear right that's pretty
much the whole story
i would think so yeah yeah
all right so what wes johnson asks a
question that i think is primarily
directed at me
uh as the as the progenitor of the
first and only anti-dutch podcast
uh any new developments on the
netherlands situation
uh that situation of course is the
ongoing
uh existence of the netherlands and and
what we're doing to try to correct that
problem
um so yeah we uh we we tried to hire a
mercenary army
turns out uh eric prince and company are
are quite busy these days so
uh you know they're we we struck out on
that front
um we've changed our tactics so uh
this is a very opportune situation to
announce
that uh the stronger by science podcast
has a sponsor bulksupplements.com
the stronger by science fireside chat
series
now also has a sponsor and that is exxon
mobil
the netherlands are like 70 of their
land is underwater
we only need about four feet of sea
level rise to overwhelm the levees
uh to take care of the netherlands
situation once and for all
so if you want to buy any fine
petrochemical supplies just go over to
exxonmobil.com
use the code stronger by science
fireside chat
at checkout uh i've been told that
most yards if you pump enough fracking
liquid
uh down into the groundwater you will
find natural gas
um take it from the fine folks at exxon
mobil
uh so yeah go over to exxonmobil.com use
the code
stronger by science fireside chat series
at checkout
and and we can we can solve the
netherlands problem together once and
for all
and i think you should also mention i'm
pretty certain i didn't read the email
closely but
most gas pumps if you just go to the
person working and say
i'd like the stronger by science
discount then they should help you out
right
they're not going to charge you more
yeah that's true yeah the the worst case
scenario
is is that you don't get a discount you
might get a discount though
so i i i would strongly recommend trying
that
okay uh moving on patrick umphrey asks
uh i would love your thoughts on
imposter syndrome
whether either of you have to deal or
have dealt with it
yes um first of all patrick umphrey
for my money i know this is going to be
a controversial statement
the best magician in the fitness
industry oh 100
so he should not have any imposter
syndrome when it comes to his magic
that's for certain um for me personally
of course you know i've i've had all
sorts of imposter syndrome
uh when i first started recklessly
speculating about fitness topics
i was too dumb to have imposter syndrome
i thought i was quite good
and you know several years ago i was
like i think i have this all figured out
then i obtained more education on the
topic and then developed
you know pretty substantial imposters
imposter syndrome because once you learn
enough to recognize like oh wow i've
been
i've been applying very super level a
superficial
level of understanding to these topics
you know
once you kind of learn how deep the pool
is you're like oh man
i thought i was in a much safer swimming
environment
but then eventually you know you you get
more comfortable with it you spend a lot
of time reading and now i'm at the point
where
uh i know the topics where i should be
diving into depth and then i know that
the topics where i shouldn't
for the most part and i think that helps
a lot with with imposter syndrome
and another um another
thing that can help with alleviating
past
imposter syndrome uh from my perspective
is remembering that it's mostly
um you know if you're just trying to
inform people
about a topic and you're interested in
the topic and you're acting in good
faith and you're not
fully attached to your ego such that if
somebody corrects you
you're gonna be just like devastated and
defensive
then i i don't think imposter syndrome
really needs to be there
you know i think we should all feel
comfortable uh
regardless of our uh credentials or
experience level if you're interested in
a topic and you think you have
uh the you know and you want to discuss
it in an
insightful way i i think uh you know i
think we should all
feel comfortable doing that and then if
you get corrected then you'll you'll
learn more from that and so i i'm
discussing it
mostly uh in the context of like
you know social media content and blog
content creating content but
it applies across the board you know if
you're going into a venture and you're
like i'm not sure if i'm qualified or
skilled enough
as long as nobody's i mean you know if
you're going to be a surgeon
brush up you know before you dive in but
for everything else as long as you're
going in with an open mind
and uh a reasonably uh
high comfort level with your ego and you
won't get super
devastated or defensive upon correction
then
should be fine i think no i feel yeah i
think uh
i think it's worth kind of like nuancing
what people
mean and are getting at with imposter
syndrome so
is it more a question of like do
i know
like am i possibly overestimating
how much i know slash how competent i am
in whatever i'm doing versus uh
do i think that i'm as good as or as
competent as
other people who are doing this thing
which aren't exactly the same thing
i i do think that i do think that a lot
of folks do tend to
underestimate their own competence while
also
massively overestimating the competence
of
other people who are doing similar
things to them
uh and so in my case
i have absolutely experienced a lot of
imposter syndrome
um like looking around especially early
in my career at other people who did
similar things to me and thinking like
oh man like i i am assuming that they
know it all and have it all figured out
and i definitely don't feel like i know
it all or have it all figured out
um therefore they're way more
knowledgeable and way more competent
than i am i found out over time that
that largely wasn't the case like in in
many cases they were more knowledgeable
and more competent than me but they
weren't as knowledgeable or competent as
i assumed that they were
um and like so i i think that uh
yeah i think it's relatively
i think that's a relatively common thing
to
just assume that everyone has it figured
out and you're the only one who's
floundering
every everyone's kind of floundering and
kind of confused and
and doesn't have it figured out as well
as as they might
uh exude and put out there publicly uh
but the the second um
like the second possible dimension of
imposter syndrome like
do i have things figured out as well as
i think i do
i think that that's uh
i think of anything that has like tended
to work in reverse for me
um so you know my experience was similar
to yours like
pretty early on i was like oh yeah man
i'm i'm
really figuring this stuff out there's a
lot of areas where i feel like i can
take a swing and add valuable insight
and now i look back on a lot of my early
work and i'm like jesus christ you were
a [ __ ] idiot like
should not have written that shouldn't
have even like stuck my toes in that
pool
um see i i think that i
systematically overestimated both
both my ability and competence and the
ability and competence of everyone
around me
um and now i'm pretty much in a place
where i'm like ah yeah
like i'm kind of dumb but that's fine uh
but it gives me comfort to know that
like most other people are like
kind of dumb too so i don't know like
we're
we're all just kind of stupid and
confused and trying to figure this [ __ ]
out together
that's a really good point because i
actually um
one of my clients that i do like
training and nutrition for
uh makes a lot of content very good
content
and we were discussing this not too long
ago and
i actually kind of said the same thing
because i talked about how i used to
have a lot of imposter syndrome and i
think it's gone down
quite a bit and i basically said like
i don't necessarily think i'm any better
than i used to be a little bit but not
by a ton but
i'm just so much more aware that most
people are bad at most things like dude
like
yeah like i don't think i i have like
just it's not like everything i do i'm
like oh
the second i start this i think i'm
exceptional at it and i have so much
more to add than anyone else but
i'm also like you know what i i there's
a lot of people missing some obvious
stuff here in this area so like i might
as well take a swing as well
so yeah it's that thing that you you no
longer overestimate everyone else's
competence and that's i told him if
that's where you should be focusing your
energy is on dealing with that side of
it because if you're waiting to like
really get out there with your content
creation for that moment where you're
like
everyone else is that competent and i'm
even more competent like you're never
going to get there
like your best hope is right starting to
recognize
how aggressively you're overestimating
everybody else's
confidence and skill level for sure okay
um taylor oxelgren asks
please discuss if you were stuck on a
deserted island
would rationing your food make you
survive significantly longer
or would energy balance just keep you
trucking along for example eating all of
your rations in one week
versus over nine weeks so
this is actually a physiology question
uh
which we tend to avoid here do you want
to take a swing at this because i i
think
i think i have an answer actually i want
to hear your answer
so i think there i think there's a third
option
that is actually the best one so uh
you know ultimately you're trying to
um so the you're dealing with energy
balance
you know calories in versus calories out
and
the amount of calories you can consume
if if we're assuming that these rations
are non-perishable
that is a fixed quantity therefore your
goal to survive as long as possible is
to minimize calories out
and so i think your best option would
not be to
ration say like eat one week's worth of
rations every week
but instead to start by fasting and
basically starving yourself
until you're like relatively close to
giving up the ghost
and then ration from there so by
initially
losing weight and also probably getting
some some depressions
in in basal metabolic rate from
you know being in in a starving state uh
that's going to lower your energy
expenditure and therefore
once you reach that point you should be
able to stretch the rations you have
longer so that i i think that that's
uh that would be a very unpleasant thing
to do but i also think it's probably the
optimal strategy
yeah i think that's accurate i mean for
me
again it's kind of like the zombie thing
like if
if a solution isn't sustainable i'm not
into it
so i think what i would do if i'm being
honest is i would just eat the
the smallest acceptable amount that
isn't just absolutely treacherous
and try to find a more sustainable
option for providing some kind of
long-term
calorie solution and if that if that
doesn't work out then i'd say well
i did my best very fair
all right uh vladimir linen asks uh
if you could design the perfect human to
excel at your chosen sport
what would that human look like and be
like and and there there were further
clarifications that it's not just like
your sport but but kind of like any
sport if we just want to riff on it a
little bit
i mean i i would uh just like
have lebron james play basketball
like or have usain bolt sprint
like i don't know i i appreciate the
question but i i take
i get so much more joy out of just
watching actual people do
insane things and like you know like
they would do all the graphics when the
olympics were on about like
how michael phelps is like built to swim
like i think
i honestly think in a lot of sports we
actually have gotten some pretty good
a pretty good idea of like what is the
ideal scenario here
in terms of structure and function and
uh
yeah i just i much prefer to just
appreciate the stuff that's for real
but that that's a that's a personality
trait for me like you know that i find
i find all works of fiction to be
annoying and tedious
like i feel like there are so many good
actual stories that i haven't heard yet
i'm like why would i
busy myself with a fake story give me
the real stuff
so i i think there's some i think there
are some answers to this
question in uh in
domains where it's obvious
that extreme body types excel but
maybe just like in the in the course of
normal human events
uh the the most possible extreme version
just doesn't
crop up ever so i i already responded to
to this comment on reddit and i said
like an eight foot tall pitcher with
extremely
extremely long arms and a completely
indestructible
ulnar collateral ligament they would
[ __ ] hose people who weighs like 400
pounds
right yeah i mean like i mean they want
any
well i guess they would weigh that much
if they were eight feet tall yeah uh but
yeah usually the the heavier pitchers
have a pretty good go of it
in terms of a long-term career yeah yeah
but just like i mean even take like
randy johnson
and add like two feet to him dude randy
johnson was the best
he was so good um
he he stopped i i think he stopped
pitching because he got bored
do you remember his slider it was it was
sick
it was so sick yeah you're really
bringing me back to my childhood i used
to love baseball
and there was that time where pitchers
were just you had uh
the ones that jump out to me you had
randy johnson you had pedro martinez
it was such a good era of pitching and
they were all so unique in their
delivery
it was it was wild uh and then like
towards the end of that era you had
like johann santana yeah uh
had his slider that just dropped off the
table when him
and francisco liriano were both on the
same team and at the height of their
powers
uh i was going to say that was must much
watch
must watch tv no baseball as ever must
watch tv but
uh it was it was fun on sportscenter top
10.
yeah oh when barry zito had that
curveball
oh yeah god that was wow what was what
was the name of
that giants pitcher that had
the crazy leg kick
was it nomo no no no um
just just talk about other pictures for
a second i'm going to remember this guy
oh man i don't so i i was going to say
uh we're we're talking about
that era back then but one of the things
that i always think of with pitchers
is uh bartolo colon pre-existed
and survived past that era his career
blows me away bartolo colon was a high
level pig
sexy tim lincicum that's who i was
thinking oh yeah yeah
undersized power pitcher who did
everything in his power to get like
maximum rotational velocity to just mow
people down
yeah he he was a bright star that burned
out fast i think partially due to his
very extreme mechanics but yeah when he
was at his best he was so fun to watch
yeah that is one of those things with
with pictures and their durability
is there are so many promising pitchers
who their career is just kind of a flash
in the pan because
it's such an extreme task to put your
body through
and i mean i can't even begin to fathom
how many
excellent pitchers get weeded out of the
process
from just having uh you know elbow and
shoulder issues
early in their career you know 13 14 15
years old
uh you wonder how many exceptional
talents there there could have been out
there who just didn't have the
durability
yeah to make it happen but you really
put your elbow through hell
man dude i i miss uh
i miss what i consider like the golden
era
of the pitching ace uh because like
have you watched baseball recently no
that's that's what i figured i i
fastidiously avoid regular season
baseball but i'll turn on the playoffs a
little bit
yeah the game has changed so much with
how pictures are used
uh because like the nerds went into
the so-called fake news data uh
and basically found that uh starting
pitchers
get progressively less effective as you
know their arm gets tired or during an
outing as
the opposing lineup sees them more times
and so you know i i remember
like you know if you had if you had two
aces two number one guys in the rotation
going at each other a a bad outing would
be if
one of them got pulled after six innings
generally they were going seven
eight deep and if they really had the
juice you you'd you'd see
a nine inning pitcher duel and that was
yeah that was great
when i was a kid that was always the the
idea you had in your head was the
you know the ace pitcher who was
drenched with sweat
you know bottom of the ninth he's thrown
170 pitches
like yeah but but he still has the juice
yeah but he looks like he just fought a
war
yeah uh you just don't see that anymore
like
there are still there are still a
handful of guys that they'll they'll put
them on the mound and just say like
you know you're out there until your
stuff stops working but
they're pulling starters in the fourth
fifth sixth inning typically these days
uh and i mean like they they have a
most teams just have a stable of
relievers that are
just carbon copies of each other there's
they're six seven they have a 97 mile an
hour fastball
decent breaking pitch put them out there
for about 30 pitches and then put the
next guy in
which like is statistically a more
effective approach to pitching yeah but
but i don't like it well you see we i we
talked about this off air
but i one of my biggest goals in life is
to never be
the curmudgeonly old man who talks about
back in my day when things were done
right
yeah but man i miss like
small ball you know i miss like the
contextual factors of baseball that were
well i mean
they also juiced the ball well that was
great
i love that how can you how can you like
small ball and the juiced ball
so i liked when back in the day you
would turn on a baseball game
and somebody uh
who may or may not be pickling their
liver
with oral anabolics someone who's uh
whose brow line and jawline changes year
over year
yeah but you would turn it on you say
what am i going to see today is it going
to be an
artful masterpiece of getting the runner
from first to third
or is this guy going to hit the ball 750
feet
i don't know but i don't know that the
game could be
uh you know so they might put up 11 runs
today who knows but
i don't know i i feel like i i enjoyed
it seems like right now baseball i
watched a little postseason and it's
pretty much like you said relievers
coming in left and right
and home running which which is even
more magnified in the postseason
yeah and home run or bust like you don't
you don't have a lot of the
ooh the guy's on second how are we gonna
get them over we got one out yeah what
what the analysts call three true
outcomes baseball
yeah you're gonna hit a home run
strikeout or walk yeah
yeah so i i kind of missed the uh i
loved baseball growing up it was my
favorite sport to play by far
and uh yeah it's it's lost some of the
organic feel i i feel like it's it's i
i admit very hypocritical because
apparently there's a huge
r baseball community uh you know as much
as i love our
statistical software apparently a lot of
those analytics are going down with a
bunch of r
nerds so you think like oh here you go
eric this is what you've been asking for
and uh i take it back i loved
the the more organic feel of the way it
used to be played yeah i simultaneously
recognized that
uh baseball is played at a higher level
than it's ever been
yeah um and the the analytics folks
have have revolutionized the sport like
they're
they're they're they solve it yeah
they're finding better ways to score
runs and prevent runs from being scored
yeah
than ever before so it is it is uh
technically a more
proficient product than it's ever been
but yeah i
i i liked the rough edges you know yeah
oh well that's fine uh are there any
other sports where you would like to
craft the perfect human um no but i did
want to hit on somebody asked
the question what's the most impressive
sports stat
so if you were moving off sports this
would be a good time to drop that
um this is basically just me
marveling at two individuals and a lot
of people are going to cringe
these people are at the top of their
game which means that you either love
him or hate him
can we take a moment to just appreciate
the fact that
lebron james and tom brady are both in
their late
70s and like you know
a legitimate regular season mvp mvp
candidate in lebron and tom brady just
won a super bowl
with a new team with no offseason and
and probably had like the third or
fourth best regular season of
of anyone in the league this year yeah i
i just for me the stat is just
date of birth how are how are they doing
it man
like i i really find it to be
uh just fascinating and so impressive to
see
how athletes are able to extend their
career uh
some athletes are able to extend their
career and not just you know
hang around for a while and make the
roster but really come in and change the
game like
it's so impressive so uh as a as a
result i'm not eating tomatoes anymore
you know i uh tom brady's got that guru
in his corner who's giving him all his
mineral drops and telling them to
stop eating everything with flavor uh
make sure you
consume enough water so you're immune to
sunburns yeah
if you're not familiar because i know
we've got a lot of international
listeners who might not be
up to date on the nfl it's called the
tb12 method
and it's it's just a whole bunch of
pseudo science and just like
weird stuff like he doesn't eat garlic
right
no garlic no onions yeah no no alliums
no nightshades
yeah so i feel like with that level of
sacrifice and you know i don't even care
about food really
just give him the trophies at that point
if he's willing to give up all that
stuff
yeah to be clear we're not promoting
this no no no no no
one of the dudes behind it i think his
name is alex guerrero
yeah um i
don't know all of the details so these
are i i will just say
just put the word alleged around
everything i'm about to say
so so we can't be sued but i'm pretty
sure back in the day he uh
he either i don't think he did prison
time but i think he got
called out for the ftc for fraud i think
he was selling something like a green
supplement
uh that he claimed cured like
cancer and aids and uh
heart disease i mean it could contribute
to like
slightly lower heart disease risk but
he's like they they get awfully picky
about those types of claims though
yeah ftc yeah yeah i i mean
eating more greens is probably a good
thing but it's not going to cure aids
um but yeah so that's that's one of the
that's one of the minds behind the tb12
method so yeah
i don't don't take anything we're saying
as
as an endorsement no no i i like to be
facetious about it because a lot of the
recommendations are so silly
but given what i do for a living i
should be clear i'm not advocating
any aspect of that approach but it's
still just one of those things where uh
his longevity's just been remarkable
he's still got zip on the ball
he does yeah i don't know why yeah uh i
mean
look at other quarterbacks who've played
into their 40s like
manning was done that's partially due to
the
the
neck injury like who knows how his
career would have gone without that
um drew brees i mean still
very competent game manager uh still
pretty accurate but
i mean he couldn't get the ball 20 yards
downfield this year no brady's older
than he is and
and he's still he's still chucking bombs
and brady
looks younger than he did 10 years ago
yeah which is weird
there's something going on there i i
don't know what it is
yeah um so
my my favorite uh crazy sports stat
is um so in the world of squash
uh this is i believe the athlete with
the longest street the longest unbeaten
streak
uh in any professional sport and that is
jahangir khan uh he was a
squash player and uh between
1981 and 1986 he won
555 consecutive matches
uh five years straight no one in the
world could beat him
um which is absolutely remarkable
that is very remarkable um the the other
one which
i'm gonna toss this out here for for uh
the australians who are listening
uh i'm i'm well aware that bradman
was was the god of uh of cricket
i don't care about cricket whoa i don't
really care about squash either
whatever those those are probably the
those
those two and uh uh corellons
greco-roman wrestling record
i would say are probably the the three
craziest to me
yeah cale sanderson also had a
remarkable run as a college wrestler
i think he was i think he was like 160
something to know
something around there but like he
basically
went to college won everything and then
was done with college it was just like a
complete four-year career four national
titles undefeated every year
just crazy you love to see it yeah
okay so uh moving on
uh identity underscore crisis underscore
asks who are your favorite fitness
influencers by sense of humor or
personality
uh i saw this one in one of the threads
and
somebody got it right uh lee peel she's
awesome
um that was me oh you put that in there
yeah oh i didn't look at the username
uh no but lee's awesome we invited her
to be part of our permanent friend group
and she uh respectfully declined
um which was probably the least cool
thing
that she's ever done i'd say it was i
mean
that might make her more cool yeah it's
that
the exclusivity yeah maybe i didn't even
think she was cool until she
decided she didn't want to be our friend
and then i was like damn she's so cool
what we've learned here is that negging
works exactly
no the thing is there's a lot of awesome
people in fitness i mean
you you you're gonna have a better
answer for this than me because i'm
i'm a new kid on the block you know i've
only been in this world for
a couple years i you know 2013 to
2019 i was just in the basement lab just
doing
research stuff so during that whole time
you were out there
networking and building uh friendships
and whatnot so what's your answer
uh yeah so um i think the the
people i just said right off the top of
my head on on reddit were
uh so the the question didn't specify
whether we're talking about like uh like
online persona versus like in-person
interactions
i am not the person to answer about
online personas because i don't really
follow that many people online that
closely
uh but in terms of people who are just
really fun to hang out with
in person lee is great
dean somerset is very funny um
one of the funnier people to to hang out
with who
you would probably expect the very least
is mike tushire
he's [ __ ] hilarious um
eric helms fun to hang out with uh
my my irish friends uh danny lennon
dude danny is so funny yeah dude he's
very funny
i don't i don't think that comes across
much on his podcast but like
danny's cool as hell yeah um
also someone who i think is like
relatively big in the
irish powerlifting scene but but uh
probably doesn't have much purchase
across the pond but
uh one one of my favorite people in the
world to hang out with
is uh garbin uh from limerick
gar is incredible yeah um
yeah i mean i i i'm going to stop
there not because there aren't more fun
people to hang out with but as the list
gets longer and longer
uh other people i've hung out with might
say
well he said all these other people why
didn't he say me
so uh i'm gonna stop there but there
there are uh i would say like of the
fitness folks i've hung out with
more of them are fun to hang out with
than not fun to hang out with
yeah um our our little area of the
fitness industry i think
i i think most of the folks are are
pretty cool pretty fun
yeah and if if i could add a couple um
i haven't actually got a chance to hang
out i mean everyone on your list that
i've met
is awesome i haven't got a chance to
hang out with
omar yet um because since we've started
really interacting a lot
you know uh covet and travel and stuff
off the table
but he's been way kinder to me than
anyone really
should like i don't think people know
how good of a dude he is he's very very
kind
um and two others i was
in finland this is on the research side
but
uh juha homie and yuha atienen
you think they do very very rigorous
solid research and you think okay a
couple brainiacs
you know you hang out with them talk
shop i'm sure it's fine
dude just sitting down having beers
talking about
golden era bodybuilding you know just
talking
classic oh it was great man like
way cooler way chiller guys than you
could possibly imagine
so two other people i throw out there
who who i
i think put more on like the athlete
side of things than like the fitness
influencer side of things
uh are uh screamer manual
and ls mclean so one one year
uh at epc we were
i think we were driving back from dublin
to
limerick and uh we were you know in a in
a small
compact car they don't you know they
they don't make big cars in ireland
uh so we were we were in there tight uh
gar was driving
lindsay was in the front seat and then
the back seat was
me screamer and ls and those are also
some thick boys so we were
we were in there like sardines and you
know
that was like an hour and a half long
drive and
i don't think we stopped just rolling
with laughter the whole way home
uh like i i legitimately had like
a stomach ache by the time we got back
just because like
i was laughing so much like we were all
just completely [ __ ] dead by the time
we got back that
that that is probably uh the
the one of the funnest hours and a half
of my entire life
the the both both of them are so funny
yeah
that whole gang was or i mean many of
the folks you've mentioned have been at
the european powerlifting conference
like yeah that's
uh so if you want to meet a bunch of
very cool very fun people that be the
place to go when it's uh
back up and running in person
[Laughter]
i would say my three favorite fitness
events i've ever been to are
the three years of the european
powerlifting conference it's
it's so fun okay uh
now that we've induced a bit of fomo um
let's induce more i guess in ourselves
maybe
uh so mickey dukes asks first place you
guys want to travel when it's available
i imagine everyone is clamoring to get
out and vacation or explore again
yeah um i i want to do a lot of
uh domestic travel uh so
international travel very cool to all of
our international
listeners uh love you but there's so
much
but there's so much uh like america's
wild
when you think of the the different
regions you can visit and how much
variety there is like
i mean i want to go to the rocky
mountains i want to go
you know out to california i want to go
to the pacific northwest
uh i'd love to go see utah i want to ski
in a
billion different locations many of
which i just named like
i want to go out west and really just
live it up
i want to see yellowstone national park
when you consider
all the the different topography the
different climates that you can access
just by hopping in a car and just
driving out there
i really i guess one of the things that
i should also mention is uh
whenever possible i prefer driving
somewhere
rather than flying like not like a super
long drive but if i could drive out west
or a fly out west and then just like hit
a few different spots by having a day of
driving to here
then a day of driving to there like i
don't really want to hop in the car and
just go straight to the coast for like
how long does it take to drive from here
to california
because you've done it right yeah i've
i've gone there and back
i think it's i think it's around 40
hours total
yeah that was going to be my guess
actually uh which is about
30 more than i'd want less than that if
you do the cannonball run though
yeah that's true but no i i really just
want to get out
mostly out west and just take a bunch of
trains and cars and
and really live it up sweet what about
you
um i just kind of want to go to the
beach
yeah i don't know it's uh it's not that
far away
but i i i just love the north carolina
outer banks
uh you know just get a little place
hang out in the sand maybe do some
fishing we could we could do that soon
yeah we could i wanted to um
i i mean i i'm i might be cheating a
little bit uh we're going to the beach
this summer
yeah we uh we're going with my wife's
family
uh and i don't foresee any travel prior
to that
um outer banks by the way one of the
coolest things about it for people who
aren't
uh familiar so it's these barrier
islands
off the coast of north carolina and
blackbeard the pirate that was where he
posted up right
that was like where he he did his thing
um but the coolest thing about it is
that
there there used to be a bunch of like
spanish
ships that would come in and they'd have
a whole bunch of horses and stuff
and there's still a ton of wild horses
out there which like for north carolina
is a unique thing
it's not like uh we're not like out in
the wilderness where there's a lot of
really cool wild animals roaming
so like uh my girlfriend and i went out
to the outer banks
a year or two ago and like we're just
walking down the beach
uh no humans in sight and just happened
upon
a group of like five wild horses and it
was like
it was pretty wild it was really really
cool so that is a beautiful area and
because of because it's kind of isolated
out there it's so chill like it's not
like there's a bunch
it's not like a busy area you just get
out there and it's
very good vibes yeah yeah i think most
people who know
about carolina beaches the first thing
that probably comes to mind is
is myrtle beach yeah the the north
carolina
barrier islands are are not myrtle beach
and i
i think that's a good thing and we
probably actually i'm going to edit this
out we shouldn't be telling people about
the outer banks because the more people
know the less chill it's going to be
uh i mean so one of the things that
keeps the outer banks from getting that
crazy is like
most of them are are a quarter mile
across like yeah
you go you go west an eighth of a mile
and you're
at the sound you go west a quarter of a
mile and you're in the ocean so i mean
you you couldn't build a myrtle beach on
the outer banks
yeah so i mean i i think it's pretty
chill it is cool
you really feel like there's a single
road
water on the left water on the right and
as many buildings as you can fit between
them
yeah like it's pretty cool yeah it's
it's great um
outside of that uh when
right before covid kicked off lindsay
and i actually had a trip to costa rica
planned um
yeah i'm sure we'll probably do that at
some point we also had
a trip for one of lindsay's sisters
planned so we uh
a graduation gift we're gonna go around
spain with her i really want to visit
spain
uh like i i want to see kind of the
the caribbean vibe like in in southern
spain
i want to go visit basque country um
i want to i want to see the pigs that
are very the
the uh the ones that iberico ham comes
from where they feed all the acorns and
whatnot
um maybe do some stone lifting
i spain seems super sweet uh and
hopefully that will be
back on the docket somewhat soon i'm
sure it will
yeah okay uh
were were there any questions that you
pulled out that you
strongly want to get two tracks um
no i think uh a lot of people wanted to
hear
about me cooking and
i just wanted to give people a little
update on that so
that that was the last thing i had
pulled out there there were a lot of
food and cooking questions so
if there was anything non-cooking
related you want to cover we can and
then we can we can end on some
some food content no let's go let's go
on to the food stuff
cool uh a lot of people want to know
about your recipes
and a lot of people want to know about
uh
quick and relatively healthy recipes uh
which i i figure yours will be one of
those and i i have one good to go too so
i figure you can start bad news folks uh
so i've been taking my minimalism
to the extremes lately in all aspects of
life
but that includes food and so i used to
do all these elaborate recipes
by the way i'm pretty annoyed at what
you pulled we haven't talked about this
i posted a rice and beans or no a rice
and chicken recipe a while ago and i
used a flavor paste with a lot of
tapioca starch
and that was the one ingredient that i
mentioned and the next day
you're out here posting about tapioca
starch as if you invented the stuff
no no citation no attribution how much
tapioca starch do you think was used in
in the particular flavor pace that you
whipped up i don't measure stuff i
i eyeball it you you eyeballed
uh the manufacturing of these sriracha
that you put on your rice and chicken
correct i mean yeah anyway
people are have grown accustomed to me
putting together these
elaborate recipes dude like i'm pretty
much just eating rice and beans now
like that is pretty much it i just pop
open a can of beans
i did get a rice cooker which i
recommend
unequivocally for all people if if you
can get your hands on a rice cooker
uh it's changed my life it's like all i
eat now
so it's pretty terrific but i don't know
if i'm gonna have a lot of recipes
forthcoming because it's i've really
gotten to the basics so like
uh most of my meals lately have just
been
rice and beans and then last night
i had for dinner a can of baked beans
and three slices of bread
so there's a recipe did you put the
beans on the bread
i didn't even do that damn dog yeah but
i've been enjoying uh i i'm sick of
stressing myself out putting together
all these elaborate meals i'm just
simplifying things
and relaxing a little bit but you said
you had a recipe
uh yeah so um just
as a note if you're interested in some
some hot
relatively easy meal prep content uh i
made some baked ziti
last week with with pretty solid macros
uh
and you know you could go check that out
check that out if you're interested in a
uh you know fun kind of off the wall off
the beaten path meal prep idea
uh but a lot of people asked about uh
healthy relatively quick like weeknight
type dinner meals um and one of the
things that i've been into
i was gonna say recently but i mean
pretty much since i was born
uh is burritos and the difference
between
a not great homemade burrito and a
really really good homemade burrito i
think
uh comes down to the chili powder you
use
so if you just get kind of like the
cheap chili powder that you could buy in
a store
i have no idea what what peppers it it's
made from but it's something that
just doesn't have a ton of flavor and
you can really really kick up your
homemade burritos
several notches just by taking like five
minutes to make your own chili powder
so there are i think two non-negotiable
ingredients for like a chili powder
you're gonna use for burritos
and that is some form of dried chili
obviously
and cumin i think those are
non-negotiable
and for for the dried chilies the world
is your oyster
there are so many great options out
there i've recently been really really
into dried morita
peppers m-o-r-i-t-a uh
they're they're relatively spicy they're
fruity they have notes of like
chocolate and raisin in them they're so
so good
uh also a big fan of ancho chili's new
mexico chili's
uh you know you can get some dried
chipotle peppers like there there are so
many options out there
uh guajillos are are always a good one
to kick up the spice a little bit
um so just buy a bunch of dried chilies
try them out see what
see what you like uh but you know just
get some dried chilies remove the seeds
if you don't want it to be spicy
throw some cumin in there uh you know
just put it in uh
like a spice grinder or like a cheap
coffee grinder
and other things that you can add into
that mix just for more flavor notes
uh peppercorns garlic powder onion
powder smoked paprika
lime zest which i would really recommend
to kind of give it a fajita vibe
blitz all of that up and so then you
have a nice
flavorful powder chop the chicken into
whatever size you want to go into your
burritos
put that in a bowl throw the the spice
mix you just made over it
stir it all up to tenderize the meat and
also again to add some nice
fajita e flavor i'd recommend just
squeezing a little bit of lime juice in
depending on the size of of the batch
you're making either like
the juice of half a lime or a whole lime
um
and then just go ahead and the the
peppers and onions that you want to put
in go ahead and chop those up
toss it all together uh cover it forget
about it for an hour
let it marinade so that that first step
should take you maybe about 10 minutes
so we're looking at 10 minutes of active
time so far
uh and then when it's time to actually
eat you just you know give it a stir
make sure everything is
is well distributed across the meat and
peppers and onions
if there are any accoutrements you want
with your burrito make sure they're
ready to go so
you know could be rice could be beans
could be cilantro
could be avocado or guacamole could be
pico de gallo
uh you know it could be some sort of hot
sauce just anything else you want in
your burrito make sure it's ready to go
because
the meat's gonna cook up pretty fast uh
and then for cooking
very straightforward get a pan put a
little bit of oil in it just so nothing
sticks right off the bat
get it over like get the heat pretty
high because you want it to sear
uh hard before a lot of liquid starts
rendering out and steaming everything
so get it really hot uh just dump
everything
into the pan make sure it's like
relatively flat and evenly dispersed
across the pan
and then the most important step which
is leave it
leave it for at least probably a good
solid three or four minutes
during that first step uh before
everything starts releasing liquid you
can get a good hard sear on it
for you know some nice mayard browning
little caramelization
even like if you like it slightly burned
i know some people do i'm not a fan of
it
you can get like a little bit of char on
it at that step if if that's what you
prefer
and then once you've accomplished that
then it's just a matter of of stirring
it around
making sure the meat gets cooked um you
don't want the vegetables to get
super super soggy so like once they
start getting
soft-finned but not soft the meat should
be cooked by that point if you've
like chopped it into the size of things
that would go in a burrito
uh and then you're ready to serve active
time for everything put together
maybe 30 minutes and given the hour
the hour time to marinade you're
probably looking at like an hour and a
half
start to finish but again only only
about 30 minutes of active time
and it's the macros can be basically as
good as you want
you can even leave the burrito shell out
and just like
serve the stuff over rice like a burrito
bowl situation
um yeah i mean it's it's lean meat
vegetables
very tiny bit of oil to to get the whole
thing started in the pan
and then everything else is up to you
it's uh it's very good very
easy and again the the macros can be
within reason just about anything you
want them to be
didn't i tell you about cumin no
are you sure
so dear listener let me recount a story
for you
uh eric got really into lentils at one
point
and uh the way he was making his lentils
is he'd pretty much just like
pop them in a pan and generally put like
some salsa or hot sauce in with them and
and that was pretty much it and then he
comes over one day
and he's like i made some really good
lentils you should try them
i tried them they were good he was like
i added a special spice to them
have you heard of cumin
well no see that's not a that's not
totally a true story
it's it that's at least 95 percent true
story
the important stuff is true i wasn't
just making lentils in a pan with hot
sauce i was making a
a soup related thing in the slow cooker
in the crock pot
but it just didn't have any flavor so
like
it was it was like a soup without all
the stuff that would give it
anything resembling taste and then i put
in cumin
after doing some reading online and i
shared that with you
and much like curiously much like with
tapioca starch
right after i tell you about cumin all
your recipes have cumin
when they did not previously after i
tell you about tapioca starch everything
you do
it's with a you know two cups of tapioca
starch so i don't know
every time i have fed you burritos
they've had cumin
every time i fed you ice cream it's had
tapioca starch
okay have any of the ice creams
you fed me had cumin actually one of
them did
really i didn't expect that that was
intended to be a smart ass joke
do you remember the one that was like
yellowish slightly brown
uh i do that had like indian flavor yeah
so that was like a
homemade uh garam masala powder and
uh a spice that comes from like a
a dried mango called amchor so it was
like garam masala and amchur
yeah i liked that ice cream i thought it
was really good yeah
it was a bold it was a bold flavor it
was
yeah it was uh it was good but yeah
there there was cumin in that in the in
the garam masala yeah
anyway uh yeah that's it uh
we're done um that's the the key you got
to end strong
hell yeah by just backing away from the
microphone and saying
i'm done i mean i got nothing else to
cover
uh hope you enjoyed this very high
effort high preparation episode of the
stronger by science podcast series
uh if you enjoyed it uh leave us a
rating on
itunes or or wherever you rate podcasts
if you didn't like it uh
also leave a rating but like kind of go
over the top when you're reviewing it
because we think those are funny
um you can uh you'll probably hear from
us again
in somewhere between four to six weeks
from now um
who knows you might hear from us again
next week might be four weeks might be
six weeks
this is not the last episode of the
podcast ever
um yeah anyway bye
thank you for listening to the stronger
by science podcast
if you enjoyed the podcast be sure to
sign up for our free newsletter to get
concise breakdowns of relevant research
as well as 28 free training programs
for all skill levels and all schedules
we hate spam just as much as you do
so we'll only email you when we have
something really interesting to share
with you
you can sign up for the free newsletter
at strongerbyscience.com
newsletter or just go to the stronger by
science homepage and click the free
programs button at the top
if you want to join in on the stronger
by science podcast conversation
be sure to check out our facebook group
and our subreddit the links for both are
provided in the description
of today's episode finally please
remember that we are not medical doctors
or registered dietitians so before you
make any changes to your exercise or
nutrition habits
be sure to check with a qualified health
care professional
once again thank you for listening and
we will be back soon with another
episode
of the stronger by science podcast
[Music]
[Music]
you